The Joe Rogan experience
Joe Rogan podcast by nine,
ladies and gentlemen,
the drunken himself,
Danieli Bolelli my friend.
How are you?
Pleasure and honor to be.
Or again,
always a pleasure and honor to have you
here,
brother.
House going.
If you hear anything in the background,
some giggling.
Danielle,
these beautiful little daughter is here
to babysit and plans didn't work out so
we'll,
we'll make it happen.
But I'll feel weird about swearing.
Well,
you should see what comes out of her
mind with on a regular basis.
So yeah,
my daughter gives me a hard time or my
wife rather gives me a hard time for
swearing in front of our daughters.
It's like there's like some period where
your is a certain point in time.
We not allowed to swear.
When they hit like 18,
you can say whatever the fuck you want
anything before.
Then people get a little squirrely.
Of course
it's hilarious because you know you
can't help it.
You know you're going to listen to some
music.
You're gonna not even crazy stuff,
but like,
Oh yeah,
she like Katy Perry at some point and so
I'm like,
okay,
whatever.
Are you listening to your song and then
she was a steal a couple of years ago.
She was tiny.
She goes into school and she started
singing to her teacher and their
teacher's like,
oh,
cute song.
You have such a beautiful voice,
and she started going like upms like a
beach.
I should know.
Please do you know the pc police is
trying to take the word bitch out of our
vernacular,
which is the latest one.
Align the new retard W.
I won't let go.
Retard.
I don't care what you say.
It's not a medical term.
It's,
it's no,
it's to retard is to slow down,
is to be behind the curve.
To be retarded is to be slow.
It has nothing to do with down syndrome
or any diseases I may have to abandon
eventually,
but for right now,
fucking staying strong,
staying strong with retard and I'm
staying strong with pitch.
What's bad with bitch?
Exactly.
Well,
it's a derogatory term for females.
It's part of the Patriarchy to engender
stand.
You know,
you'd done understand because you're a
white male.
You need to check your privilege.
Mr Kelly,
have you not checked your privilege?
Yeah,
I saw your tweet about checking your
pedigree,
realized I was thinking about checking
my privilege yesterday.
I didn't though.
I thought about it.
I thought about the fact that he
wouldn't be.
Even though it's a way that people can
silence you.
I mean that's essentially what it is.
I mean the idea behind it has some
merit.
You know,
the idea that there are people that have
privilege in life and they need to
understand that.
I think it's a valid term when you're
talking about minorities and poor people
and people on welfare and people in
foreign countries that have no
healthcare and they're poor,
I believe support 100 percent that,
but it gets used a crutch to silence
people and it gets used as a crutch for
people who lack the intellectual vigor
to engage in an honest debate and
discussion.
They say,
you need to check your privilege.
I love watching videos of people that
are just really not that bright,
but they're like getting involved in
those debates and they have that weapon.
Check your privilege.
It's like it's like a fighter that
doesn't really know how to box,
but as an awesome overhand,
right.
That overhand rights in the other boxes
like pitch,
get out of here with that overhand
right.
I didn't see that shit coming a mile
away.
Check your privilege.
So not that easy.
You're fucking argument sucks.
No,
I mean I get it because there are the
people who are,
oh,
you know,
we live in a colorblind society.
Everything.
There is no more risk season.
We can all be equal and if you are
trying to argue anything but you are a
reverse racist,
then I can see how some of these guys
that are addicts themselves because they
are ignoring the fact that there's a
whole history behind it and when they
say we started the race evenly,
it's like,
well somebody has their shoots.
Things tie together for 50 years,
bullshit not.
And so he's like,
no,
the reason the way you've been raised,
that's bullshit.
But at the same time when you turn 18 to
everything is about what happened 200
years ago is like,
come on man.
It's a fine balance there.
There's a website that a twitter handle
that I don't,
I don't follow them on twitter because I
don't want them to know that I follow
them,
but what I did is I bookmark them and I
go to her page all the time.
That's.
And her thing is about being child free,
Hashtag child free and I mean this
woman's entire fucking twitter feed is
all about how happy she is that she
doesn't have a child and it's one of
those,
you know,
me thinks the does protest too much.
You know,
it's like when you go to it,
it's like,
oh my God,
like is this,
your whole existence is like being happy
that you don't have a child.
Like this is so bizarre.
It's a bizarre hang up,
but that bizarreness is that,
that's a characteristic of human beings.
Like they can get caught up in a bunch
of different weird ways of thinking and
one of them can be just fucking
meandering on and on constantly about
racial issues.
Oh yeah,
of course.
And it works.
By the way.
Have you seen Al Sharpton's girlfriend?
Jesus?
Louisa.
Really?
Oh my God.
That good?
Oh my God,
she's a fucking 10,
a young 10 with their arms around this
crusty old dinosaur fucking suitcase.
Pimp will have these sharp on the Dead
Sea.
It is Lee officially dead.
I don't know.
Fucking thousand.
Seven hundred and 50.
He's disgusting.
He's just a creep.
He's just a suitcase pimp,
you know?
It was just one of those guys.
It's just a hustler.
He figured out his way through that
Tawana Brawley case where it was some
false rape accusations.
He was blaming all these white people.
It's again,
it's the same thing.
Race,
pimp.
Look at her kapow.
Oh,
oh.
And that's just one picture.
By the way,
this is a weird thing that happens with
people's heads when they lose weight.
You when people get really fat,
their heads get big.
That's how sharp sharp to now.
He lost a lot of weight.
He has stomach stapled and that's only
one photo over.
She's 35 years.
Ah,
well,
good for.
Yeah.
What do they talk about?
Crayons.
Shit.
She's not that young.
Actually.
Thirty five is pretty stylish.
Beautiful.
Somebody is not watching their little
show.
Somebody is sitting in Danielle Ebola,
his lap,
Kiehl's demons or no,
she's.
She's done.
Didn't say hi to everybody.
Okay.
I'll hug you the whole time about that.
You can sit in my lap.
Watch your show.
Be the first show ever were a little kid
is here during the podcast.
Yeah,
that should be.
You're so cute.
I'm going to have to let it slide.
I'm going to have to just these ones to
watch TV or anything.
What time?
Well,
right now it is a 1:10.
You can watch tv if you want.
Do you want to?
She's watching her show mode or less.
That was when my daughter was three was
one of the coolest moments ever.
My daughter was three wounds.
Skin.
I took their scared.
Skim Skim when?
When one daughter was two and the other
one was for.
That's when I started skiing.
Yeah.
I just think it's good to just get kids
doing shit as much as possible.
I'd take them to dance class and
gymnastics and I teach them martial
arts,
but I think it's good to just get them
used to traveling and doing things,
but when she was three we are putting
all this stuff into her little bag and
she's a little badge carriers how we
travel and she likes to pull her own bag
and she didn't have her helmet in the
bag and she had everything zipped up and
right when she finished up and I'll buy
my honey didn't put your helmet and she
goes,
shit,
something so adorable.
I bought a three year old gone and my
wife and I would just like,
oh no,
she didn't do it right.
So what's that?
Bid Sees what I.
The deal that I struck with her was,
I don't care if you do it around me.
I get it.
That light to wait too.
But you do not.
There are places.
Where do you do at school?
Around other kids.
He,
Frodo,
fewer teachers?
No,
I told him so one day we were driving
home from school and she let slip up,
something like that.
I,
she does shit and I'm like,
is she looked at me?
He's like,
don't worry,
I don't say it.
That's cool.
I just say here and I'm like,
okay,
that's fair.
And so she sees that she had to go ahead
and so she liked.
She just kind of got.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's tricky because it's a totally
acceptable for adults in normal
rational,
but you know,
it's not in certain circles.
It's that whole thing.
The whole censorship in language thing
is such a bizarre aspect of being a
human being.
These forbidden words that we use that
essentially are interchangeable with
words that are okay.
Like what drives me crazy is when
someone goes fricken fricken guy with
his fricking thing,
like I hated nuts.
Oh whoa.
What kind of bizarre corporate world we
live with Applebee's existence.
Are we floating through here fricken
night?
That I should be nuts.
It's weird.
It's weird and it's why.
I mean,
I don't Overdo,
wait,
the fight can check it out,
but I don't try to censor myself around
there in anything you do in anything
that I do is kind of like dc is how I
am,
right?
This is.
I'm now going to out of my way to make
it extra weird.
But I'm like,
oh I am is I am.
And I like talking to kids.
Not exactly like they are adults because
I'll do today aren't right.
But at the same time,
not treating them like they are fucking
stupid.
Where are you just studied them like a
Google God,
that kind of stuff all day long.
It's like,
come on man,
it kids that are way smarter than.
You'll give them Canadian too.
And if you,
if you work with them like that from the
get go,
they will surprise you with time and
time again with the stuff that they can
say back to you.
Oh,
without a doubt.
I remember when I was a little kid,
people I still to this day remember
people treated me like I was more on and
talking to me stupid.
I'm gonna.
Remember thinking why?
When I have kids,
I'm never talking to them like that,
so I talked to my kids like they're my
friends,
like I'm very sweet to them and very
nice and very understanding if they're
crying about something that doesn't make
any sense,
but I,
when I explain something to them,
I explained it to them like an adult and
I know their heads only that big,
so it can't possibly be smartest man.
Smart man.
They are my six year old can read now.
Wow.
Which is interesting because I had a
shirt on the other day that said nine
fucking oranges because,
uh,
I had this a bit in my act is based on a
true story where,
um,
I had my,
a power cut off in my house because I
didn't pay my bill.
In fact,
when I was young I was very responsible.
I wasn't even broke.
I just didn't pay my bill.
And so the guy came by and turn the
power on.
It seemed like a nice guy.
And after we turned the power on and go,
hey man,
I had an orange tree in this yard of
this House I was renting.
And I go,
if you want to grab one of those
oranges,
man,
I go,
they're really delicious.
And he goes,
oh,
okay,
thanks.
So the guy goes out there and he takes
nine fucking orange and I swear to God,
man,
I was 20,
I want to say maybe 26,
27 time.
That was 20 years ago and to this day
there's still times I'm in my car and
I'll be driving around.
I'll just go nine fucking orange and
talked about it on stage.
And it's really true.
It is a true story.
And so this dude gave me this tee shirt
at one of my shows that just said nine
fucking orange.
Orange is on it.
I wish I had it on right now.
That's great.
But I,
I worked for one of the shows,
one podcast I worked for.
But anyway,
uh,
I,
I brought it home and my daughter goes,
I know what that says.
That's a bad word.
Bad word.
A busted.
Why didn't even know she knew that word
first of all.
I mean she's the are a couple of once in
a tiny moment.
My wife runs a tight ship.
Really?
I try to.
I try to keep it,
keep it very pg.
You can try only once,
but that our thighs.
I remember when she was tore something
where I drop something and for the rest
of the day she went on repeating doc doc
doc and I'm like,
I'm glad you think it's a doc.
What I say,
yes,
that's what I said.
What I ended up and it's like there's no
way.
No Way.
It's impossible.
Yeah,
there it is.
Brian Cowen,
Bryan countered I nine fucking orange.
I see the fucking is covered by my name,
but it's nice when I said that wasn't
Brian Count when I got back from a
hunting.
So that one was before hunting or 58
after.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
we did two,
two podcasts in row.
One before and one after hunting.
We went up to this island,
Prince of Wales in the middle of Alaska.
Terrible trip.
The well,
it was beautiful though.
It was beautiful.
It was a great trip.
It was just unsuccessful hunting trip,
but there was.
What was great about it was when I came
back home,
I really appreciated civilization.
Oh yeah.
I really.
We slept in a tent.
It was wet.
Everything was wet.
Sleeping bag was wet.
It was just.
It was miserable.
It's like 40 degrees.
Just poured every day.
It was so much humidity that like inside
the tent,
like I would turn.
I had this little miner's light.
Anything like a forehead light.
I turned it on and you'd see the entire
tent was filled with little floating
beads of water.
It was just that much humidity in there.
When did you guys go with the first week
of October?
It was too late.
Yeah,
it's late.
Yeah.
It was too late for the area that we
were hunting in because the deer had
already moved down.
We were at the top where the water is,
where the lakes are,
and the deer had already moved down.
There's water up there.
Lakes that have no fish,
giant lakes that are lakes that are only
there because of rainwater.
Wow.
Giant lakes of rainwater and he drank it
because there is no beavers.
He just dip your thing right in the
water.
We drink right out of the lake.
That's beautiful in itself is beautiful.
It is.
It's amazing in that sense.
Like I was prepared for diarrhea
everyday.
I bet that it never came.
They were saying if you get Giardia,
like you wouldn't get Giardia.
Giardia comes from animal poop and the
only way you would get that as if there
was a beaver up there,
but um,
you could like run into a bear and bear
could have pooped in there because
that's a bear poop in your mouth.
Yeah,
that would be.
I can see how it sinks would be more
fun.
Yeah.
But it's such an enormous lake.
The odds of you getting any substantial
amounts.
I mean,
the reality is unfortunately we're
constantly getting fecal matter and
stuff in your body and like,
even if you're a person who only eats
plants,
they say that one of the best ways that
vegans get vitamin B 12 is from bugs
that they inadvertently eat that are on
their food.
Just kind of hilarious that the other
day I handed out this glass of wine to
this lovely lady and she grabbed it and
she goes about this secret and she
looked and she's like,
oh,
there's a bag inside,
and she handed it back to him and I
think I was already buzzed.
Then after that I look at it and was
like,
just shrug my shoulder.
I'm down the bug into wine,
and it was tasty.
Nice.
Bugs don't taste nearly as bad as people
think.
They do take it from me.
From my days at fear factor I have.
I've eaten quite a few bugs.
It's more in your head?
Yeah,
there's anything.
I mean I wouldn't go for like nasty.
We are looking cockroach from outer
space kind of thing,
but you know,
little box or whatever.
No big deal.
I had a Madagascar hissing.
Cockroaches like the site,
remember pagers.
That's a pager.
That's Matt,
giant Madagascar,
hissing,
cockroach.
I think they were referred to.
That's pretty good.
Australian,
they're not bad man.
Now was.
I guess you know what it is,
is not.
The thing itself is what he does.
Crawled through.
It's all in your head.
Yeah.
It really is all in your head with was
crawl through.
Yeah.
Disgusting.
But the ones that we got,
they were raised on a farm,
you know,
they were raised for movies and stuff
like that for show business.
It's really in decades,
ultra sun,
let's say.
Isn't that amazing that there's so many
cockroaches,
there's so much of a need for
cockroaches that there is someone who
raises them for television that I've
never heard before.
Crazy.
That's that seed that is take the ride
and they would have millions of them.
Man.
These guys that have cockroaches.
But I was around them so often it just
became nothing.
Right.
And I've watched people eat them and you
know,
I forget what it was.
Oh,
it was um,
one of the girls from a soap opera.
It was like a celebrity fear factor and
I made her a deal that if she ate,
she ate one of the cockroaches to move
on,
that I would eat a cockroach and she
wouldn't even eat a cockroach.
She ate a worm instead.
Like I would rather eat a roach than a
worm.
But even from my book,
see a boardroom I think is filled with
dirt.
Yeah,
probably.
I mean the dirt.
But then again it could approach is not
exactly a rap being himself day and
night and taking showers is.
I'm telling you,
eating,
it was like,
it was very,
like no taste at all.
Very mild.
Just exploded in my mouth and I crunched
it.
But it was a very mild.
Like if I had to,
if I was starving,
I would eat a bowl of those things.
No problem.
If they're starving,
I think that are too many things.
That one doesn't say.
It makes you a gag a little just because
it just feels gross in your mouth.
Reality of like the actual flavor of it.
It's not that bad.
Not too bad.
Nice.
It's not.
No worries.
Yeah.
People are saying that in other
countries that bugs are becoming like a
viable form of protein.
Oh yeah.
They say it's really clean.
Protein is less fattening than most
other types of proteins.
So
yeah,
if you can get over the disease grows
supposed to be actually good for you.
Yeah,
probably not.
Just less fat.
I mean,
how much fat is in a bug?
Yeah,
I would imagine next to nothing super
lean,
right?
Yep,
Yep.
So they even have like cricket,
like snacks that you can buy.
I'd like hiking places.
The SELAC please.
Cricket bars.
I've done that before.
There wasn't a sound coming out of her
ears.
Ear Buds.
I was wondering what that was.
I thought maybe someone was outside
cranking music of these things fell off
and I need to just.
Okay.
You come to listen to the other one.
I'll just.
A lot of days went up.
She's so adorable.
It's all right,
man.
Yeah.
I had that before with a friend of mine
was from Wahaca,
Mexico and so one of their traditional
thing,
they will have this entire plates field
with crickets and you know,
he didn't grow up where you grew up out
here.
Right.
His parents are all into that stuff.
So one day he's like,
I have to try after try he order a seat.
That is what huck and restaurant.
And he just looked at it and I could see
he's about to throw up like any cycled
that.
Right.
He's just like,
come on,
it's not that bad and I have to say
them,
you can eat them,
but I can think of about 10,000,
572 things that are better than that are
not the tastiest in the world and you,
they look at you,
they are,
they are not that tidy so they have
their eyes so that you can clearly see
them.
I'm crunching on some creek.
A tie right now is it?
But why is that?
Why is that gross?
But like a lobster is okay.
No,
I mean there are some stuff that I agree
with you some seeing sir.
It's thought that social conditioning
season you just broke up with the idea
that that's normal and that it's normal,
but otherwise it's not.
It's just as we are,
does a bunch of other stuff.
Yeah,
because I mean essentially like crabs
and lobsters and crustaceans,
they're really like bugs are bugs that
just live in the ocean or water bugs and
lobster or one of the few things that I
can't quite.
I mean the whole thing of boiling them
alive.
That freaks me out really.
I mean,
other stuff,
he's like,
I have no problem.
You know,
you second the hunting thing,
you know,
you go out,
you hand and anamolies footy as a good
life and you killed them.
You eat them.
Totally make perfect sense to me.
Boiling alive.
Something actually involving torture to
make sure that you get to eat it.
I feel like I can't eat something else.
You know?
I can eat and again,
it doesn't have to be a vet I can eat.
I have no problem with the whole eating
meat thing or writing or any of that.
Just the pain of pirates.
She's like,
come on man.
Well,
if it makes you feel better,
they say that lobsters lack the nerve
endings to feel pain.
Really?
Yeah.
It's.
Will they also regenerate limbs and
stuff?
A lobster loses a leg.
It just grows rack in that case.
But you're on the lobster.
Yes.
If you really wanted it humanely,
eat lobster,
you just hack their arms off and they
just keep letting them grow their arms
back clause.
You could do that.
It would work.
I don't know how long it would take to
regenerate a claw,
but they,
they regenerate
the same way like crocodiles.
Do they regenerate as well?
Some lizards do.
I remember when I was a kid,
I went to,
my maternal grandfather was in by the
seaside and you know,
I would hardly ever see him.
So it was kind of a new thing and he was
already weird enough.
And when they um,
I'm thirsty,
I wake up in the middle of the night,
I go to the fridge,
I opened the fridge and he's fucking
giant lobster,
jump out of the features,
start running away because I was like,
what the hell out.
The weird thing about lobsters is they,
they live in the ocean,
but you can ship them in a box and they
don't even have to be in water and they
get to you,
like from Maine and they're all live
everyday in Vegas.
They have lobster shipped in from Maine
to the restaurants.
Just like how the hell,
like how the,
what are these things like they don't
even have to breathe.
I know like how many days can they go
without breathing?
I have no idea,
but it's freaky is definitely fakey.
Yeah,
freak as it comes.
She needs some sort of a television show
for this to work television show right
there.
She's not watching.
Watching.
It's more interesting to interrupt.
We should have worked this out,
man.
I would've brought my kids over.
Then you could have a little party and
we just heard yelling and fucking play
would have been wild and crazy over
there.
Yeah.
I don't know what it,
what it feels,
but the one thing I do know is when you
throw a lobster in the water and the
water boils,
they tried to get out.
Yeah.
So I'm not buying it.
I don't buy it either.
It sounded a little weird to me.
The convenient thing that people say,
it's like,
no,
they don't feel anything.
They like it.
Actually.
It's like a sonar to them.
You know?
It's like they have these pleasant sawn
and all of a sudden the day die
peacefully and go to lobster heaven and
all is good to hear music and they just
expire.
They want to go to their dad.
Relative lobster was been in your Paul
to before and they are uniting lobster
heaven and all is well and a well.
One thing that is interesting about like
prey animals like deer and antelope and
stuff is that they believe now that like
when an antelope gets captured but like
a lion or something like that.
Then when the lion bites down on it that
it's brain floods with chemicals and an
almost sort of gives up,
like it kicks a little bit,
but it just sort of gives up and it
doesn't fight like ses if lack of a lion
captured like a Predator,
you know,
some other Predator like a leopard or
something like that.
They would fight for their rights.
They would go crazy and make screaming
noises and everything.
But antelopes just like,
oh,
this is just my place in the world to
pray.
I got cold,
so okay,
I'll check it out next to life.
We'll see soon.
Come back as a draft or some shit.
What's your take on that kind of stuff?
Do you,
do you actually send my believing
reincarnation w what's your take?
Um,
I don't not believe in it because I
think the idea of life itself is so
bizarre.
The idea that we have a soul,
that we have consciousness that we can
see through our,
that we navigate with sound and feel and
memory.
I mean,
it's,
it's so,
so,
so bizarre that reincarnation is not
outside of the question.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't know if there is such a thing as
a soul.
I don't know what this life is.
I don't know.
Like there's this life.
Is this a finite experience where you,
you're born and then you die?
Or are you drifting in and out of
parallel experiences every time you go
to sleep and wake up.
I mean,
are you on the same timeline constantly
when you wake up and you have this
memory of your existence in this life
that you,
uh,
are you sure that that's exactly how
everything goes?
I mean,
just because all the people in your life
seemed to think that that's everything,
how everything goes.
How do you know that you didn't go to
bed last night with a totally different
existence and wake up with a memory of
this life that you're living right now
just completely embedded in your head.
And we don't know.
That's negative.
Fame.
Moza,
Schwan's when the butterfly,
right to the whole,
uh,
ways to sage,
Twan.
So it was all like,
uh,
they asked him about these many say I
had this dream that I was a butterfly,
but now I'm puzzled because I don't
remember anymore.
I don't know if I'm really transformed.
I was dreaming that I was about their
flight or if I'm actually a butterfly
and this is the butterflies dream,
thinking that she's trans.
So.
And that's the paradox off.
You'll never fucking know.
No,
I had a really intense dream once that
was so realistic that to this day it
haunts me because I was some sort of an
animal,
like a wolf or something along those
lines.
And we were sneaking up on this deer and
the deer herd,
like a branch snap or a leaf move.
And I could smell fear.
And I remember smelling fear,
like smelling the tingling in this
animal's body as it was thinking about
bolting as it was wondering whether or
not it heard anything.
And I also remember smelling water.
I could smell the water that was
dripping.
And then I woke up.
I remember thinking like,
what the fuck is going on?
Because I remember there was other
similar animals near me,
some wolf like animals near me.
And we were like communicating without
words in some sort of strange primitive
way.
It was a very short dream,
but I woke up.
But I remember thinking,
wow,
that was an intensely realistic
experience because I didn't feel like
while it was going on,
I wasn't like,
oh,
I'm a person that thinks it's a wolf.
You know?
It was like I was in this.
This animal's mind of course could
easily be imagination.
Sure.
But then again,
it's some of those dreams.
I know exactly what you mean,
but some of the things that are weird,
there's a staff that I know what I've
experienced.
And then sometimes there's something
that clicks seen that he's like,
this is not part of my life,
this is what I'm feeling right now is
way beyond the range of my experience.
This is not part of the game.
And that's what I find.
I find it creepy,
you know,
I find it really interesting like you
ever seen the legends of the fall,
which I really liked the movie.
I could only watch it with at one time
and I could never watch it again because
he freaked the hell out.
There was one scene where,
um,
if you guys are gonna Watch legends of
the fall and you plan to do it,
skip the next main articles.
I'm going to give spot from spoiler from
20 years ago.
Not exactly big spoiler,
but there's that scene where,
uh,
Brett's but brother get killed in one
word.
One,
he goes berserk and he kind of goes
behind enemy lines and he,
uh,
end the next CEO,
sees you seek coming back into camp and
he's covered in blood.
He has a German scalps all over him and
he's walking through the camp and
everybody's opening up to let him go
through nobody's saying award.
There's the sense of,
and there's the sense about him that
he's kind of larger than life.
He has done this crazy thing of going
single handedly again,
killing probably 10,
15 guys,
something insane,
and yet there's this sense of extreme
sadness.
Like all that power,
all that warrior ability doesn't give
him what he truly needs,
which he still got back his loved ones.
You know that.
So that combination of extreme larger
than life power and torque tragedy that
you can do,
you know,
that hold that power doesn't really help
you.
When I saw that scene,
he was so familiar in a way that it's
not mine,
you know,
it's no out my life up until that point
that been.
He had no parallel whatsoever in my
experience.
And he wasn't like any other movie where
I see something and he's like,
oh cool.
I can kind of relate to that on some
degree.
Any heat me like,
oh my God,
I know that feeling so damn well and
that I think about it like where do I
know that feeling,
you know,
20 years ago or whenever I saw legends
of the fall,
um,
and there's nothing in my life to mirror
that.
Not even a tiny bit.
The imagination is such a wonderful,
incredible thing.
It's just,
it's so impossible to really understand
the boundaries of the imagination and
people can imagine memories.
I mean,
there's been moments where people have
been talked into remembering things by
like through experiments,
like through with,
with someone would counsel them and give
them a memory of the past and then coach
them through this memory and then time
will go on and they'll think that that
was a real memory.
Oh yeah.
And what does that mean?
The imagination itself is such a bizarre
aspect of being a human being.
The ability to like this wolf thing that
I had in my mind essentially that was my
imagination.
I mean,
the only other option is what is it a
suppressed memory from my genetics from
a long time ago when I was some sort of
an animal,
but you know,
I mean the idea of evolution is
essentially that human beings in 2014
are the result of millions of years of
change,
of natural selection,
of all these different slow processes
that have led us to being this thing
that we are today.
But this thing has a direct link to
whatever the fuck survived from that
gigantic asteroid that hit the Yucatan
and was what?
Some in one and a half miles deep,
like slammed.
The thing was like five,
five miles deep into the earth within
the first,
second and a half.
Killed everything.
Everything larger than,
you know me,
I think Mckenna used the term a chicken.
Everything larger than a chicken.
So just like as a point of reference and
just weird little mammals,
rat things survived.
So somehow or another from 65 million
years ago,
those weird little rat things that
survived became CEO,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
Hold the my mouse around us as
inevitable.
What is,
you know.
But,
but there's no direct chain to any
wolves.
There's no direct chain to any mean.
Even the lower hominids were even the
ones that ate meat.
They did.
There weren't on all four.
They weren't.
So there's no.
I have no past with wolves.
Nope.
So if that's the case,
like what is that thing?
Is that just total imagination?
Is it just the psychedelic chemicals
that flood your brain during heavy rem
sleep?
Just creating a,
a beautiful image for you to try to
conceptualize and wrap your head around?
Or are you drifting in and out of
realities?
Are you mean,
are you a monkey one day,
you know,
and then you go to sleep,
you wake up and you've done all,
you have your life and everything is
normal.
But were,
were you a monkey yesterday?
Probably some would argue that a monkey
right now,
while everybody argues that,
I mean it's obviously one of those
stoner conversations that you have.
Like how do you know anything about
that?
I don't know what you're saying.
Yeah.
But those,
those conversations are so common.
Like,
how do you know that,
you know when you go to bed and you wake
up and more than the youth,
same person,
but you don't know.
And that's the weird thing about going
to bed is that everyone wants to do it.
Everyone wants to sleep and everyone's
scared to die.
Everyone wants to shut off temporarily,
but no one wants to shut off
permanently.
Oh Yep.
Is a very,
very odd existence because you know,
if there were any guarantees,
if throughly people,
that's why I don't really buy a lot of
the religious people think they say I
believe in an afterlife isn't that is
like if you're really dgl,
it'd be way more relaxed about a lot of
things in life because you wouldn't have
that fear of that is like,
well,
do I have to be afraid of.
There's nothing to be afraid of it.
It would be cool.
And he's like,
great,
you know,
I do my thing here.
Whenever I check out,
I check out and I go to this other cool
place.
Evidencing is great.
There's no reason to fear the Fed,
that people are obviously not thrilled
with the notion of dine makes me think
that they don't believe it half as,
as they actually do it.
Well,
belief systems are very strange.
It can,
it can really seem in your mind to be
absolutely real and you will explain
these beliefs to someone else and they
will tell you that you're an idiot.
Like I was on a set once I was doing
this thing and uh,
I was talking to this girl and her
sister,
they seem totally normal.
And then the girl,
I don't remember what we were talking
about,
it had something to do with gay people.
I don't remember what it was.
It was something like about gay marriage
or gay people.
They were talking about how the woman
was saying that it's a sin.
It's.
And I thought she was joking.
I really thought she was joking because
it was a set like intelligence such as
like,
well,
it's a sin,
it's a sin.
And,
and,
and then I realized she was serious and
I go,
um,
so you think that God created people
that are gay and then he did it like as
a goof,
like a trick.
Like what is that?
And she goes,
no,
you don't understand.
She said that this the devil scales of
covering your eyes.
Wow.
And I said,
the devil scales are covering my eyes.
I'll never forget that term.
That's the devil scales.
I didn't know the devil Ed scale.
That's when it's starting to run.
What?
No,
no,
no.
I mean,
she was friendly.
She was just,
um,
who knows,
man,
who knows?
There was this girl and her sister and
the girl,
the one that I was originally talking to
seem totally normal,
but her sister was just out to Liz
launch.
Right.
And that's the devil scales are covering
your eyes.
It was just about gay people.
That's.
No.
Yeah,
that's quite pretty key right there.
You admitted.
But it's like people pick and choose
shit,
man.
I know this dude who is really
religious,
but he has religious tattoos.
Like motherfucker,
you gotta read the whole Bible are not
supposed to text.
I could have read all of it and that's
supposed to tattoo yourself.
Funny.
In fact to me is like when people say
either they are pro or against anyone
really John seely because it's like when
somebody tells me they are Christiano or
Muslim or Buddhist or whatever,
that maybe he's not telling me anything
really because as you say,
people pick and choose what they want
out of that.
So one guy's way of being Christian.
Subtly awesome.
There are going to be super nice people
and their belief system elps them being
nicer people.
Yeah.
The next guy,
the our way of being Christian because
they pick and choose the crappiest part
out of the Bible is scary as hell and
their way of being.
Christian is around 40 or life and also
to me,
the label itself.
I'm not interested in an argument about
whether one religion is good or bad
because the reality is that every one of
them you're going to find at least some
good part in some.
There's a lot more than in others,
but you're gonna find at least a little
bit.
That's good in just about scene and
usually I find also tons of crap I'm
interested in which pirates will peak
and allow those parts inform your
behavior.
How do,
how do you behave based
on your beliefs?
That's what the interest me.
Yeah.
It's like like the idea of drugs,
like all drugs,
not just drugs.
The idea is like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a religious person or I'm a
Christian.
Well,
Fred Phelps.
Phelps was the Christian.
Right.
And then there's like rupert sheldrake
is also a Christian.
This very,
very different ideologies at work here,
but they're both calling themselves
Christian and Fred Phelps is just as
evil mean creepy old fuck.
That eventually died.
Is rotted in his own filth and fucking
anger.
Yup.
That's exactly how it is.
That's why to me,
even the whole antireligious,
the watson thing gets through romantic
because it's like,
oh,
can stay on.
Sorry.
Terrible Muslims are all evil.
It's like,
do you really think every single one out
of millions of people who belong to the
sinks,
they are all bad people,
man.
It's like there's,
there's the nice lady will pick the
parts that are all about being nice to
your neighbor and charity or whatever
and that's or way of being Christian or
Muslim or Buddhist or whatever the hell
it is and he's awesome and there's
nothing wrong with deep and he's
actually pleasant and I'm sure we'd
actually helps our life.
Either beliefs,
yes,
those are scary and anybody going by
those beliefs.
Then you see it in action and is not
helping an old lady cross the street is
chopping people set off because they
don't believe the same thing you do.
That's where you get.
That's the freaky part,
but I don't even care what it's people
and again,
always Saturday about which one is the
one who does all this shit.
It's not even just 30 days alone because
if you look a communist,
dictatorship,
Nazis,
they've all done anything.
The name of it,
it's totalitarianism.
You know?
It's that idea of everybody needs to
leave according to my way of life and
anybody who doesn't need to be squashed.
That's the scary thing that I got really
self,
which a label is attached to it
regardless of which set of clothes.
It's the site aware.
He's the same shit.
Yeah.
Ideologies or they're problematic
because when you feel like you force
yourself into like a framework,
you force yourself into a pattern.
Anything that's outside of that
framework is like automatically not to
be considered and when you have like
rigid thinking anytime you ever really,
except like rigid thinking like,
Hey,
you shouldn't rob people.
you shouldn't go around stealing.
You shouldn't around go around stabbing
people.
You shouldn't mean there's,
there's rigid things that in a sense
that like a pretty clear cut.
It makes sense because they're causing
harm and there's.
But there's also,
there's ideologies that are just,
you get locked into them and you're
forced to think that way because of it.
Like people that will tell you that this
religion is correct because this
religion is the truth and now they'll,
they'll force themselves to like be
stuck in that little box.
Right,
and you don't want to admit that you
ever fucked up and lived 20 years of
your life believing in some nonsense so
then you're stuck.
You're stuck in this little box and that
could be atheism just as much as it can
be Christianity,
because I've met a lot of atheists and
I'm like,
listen,
you're
in a religion,
you're just going to read the religion
called atheism and they like want you to
proclaim.
You're an atheist.
Like I know this dude that's an atheist
and he gets upset if I say,
I don't know.
You know,
I say that to me is the most honest
thing you can say is on a about a lot
about stuff of the universities.
I don't know because that's the reality
of it.
He hasn't had any really extreme
psychedelic experiences either.
None.
In fact,
he's very smart guy,
but his ideas are like only based on his
own personal experiences and what he's
learned and what he's red and he's a
very smart person.
He's very aware of religion,
but he's like so adamant about
proclaiming there is no god and I'm
like,
look dude,
I have seen things on mushrooms that are
way crazier than an old man with a book
check in your name and the cloud and
leading you to pearly gates and there's
a bunch of people with wings.
I've seen some shit that's way crazier
than that so that I don't think that's
real,
but there's no evidence whatsoever in
my,
uh,
in my estimation that that's,
that exists.
But the idea that there might be some
universal consciousness that we want to
describe as a god and it's just not this
old man in the clouds wearing robes.
It's just something maybe even beyond
the realm of humanity beyond the realm
of the possibility of us understanding.
I don't see any evidence for that,
but I'm not.
I'm not throwing it out.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
I mean,
if somebody and get some crappy
fairytale that subs really poorly at
Eaton and his bad screenwriting,
it doesn't take a genius to figure out
what,
okay,
that's just bullshit and I can see it.
But if you define God in some other way,
how the hell do you know that,
you know,
once you're a drag,
just the most scholarly type of
fairytale,
everything else is up for grabs because
nobody really knows.
I mean universities.
That's why to me it's kind of hard to
have the discussions about religions
even like the books ever written about
religion because usually people don't
like organized religion is because they
are big fans of um,
you know,
kind of a hardcore materialist worldview
where it's all about what you can see
and touch and nothing else exist.
So then you write a book that pleases
those guys and doesn't play the
religious folks.
That's great.
You still have an audience.
But if you argue for something more sub
though,
if you argue for sensing that's
basically not dogmatic,
either religiously dogmatic or in a
hardcore materialistic form,
dogmatic,
then you're shit out of luck in terms of
fighting.
And audience,
because you are,
there's no niche that you jumping to
right away,
right?
It's not just one simple,
you know,
there's those guys that are going to be
right behind you.
You're asking people to be aware on a
moment by moment basis so they'd urgent
just seemingly,
you know,
binding to a dogma,
spouting the ideology,
spouting the disease,
what we believe one,
two,
and three year asking people to leave
life without relying on a damn recipe
that you apply at every little thing you
run into when instead you to use their
notes to use their eyes.
The situation right now I'm able to,
uh,
in this particular case,
I'm going to do what he's saying.
In his other case,
the same thing that work two minutes ago
is not appropriate and it's not the
right thing to do.
It's kind of like in fighting,
you know,
it's like there's a rhythm to things.
There's a timing to things.
And going with that plan as a rigid
plan,
going in with a plan is great,
but going with that are easy to plan.
They are not going to change it
regardless of what's in front of you is
the recipe for death.
You know,
you're gonna.
Ask her up.
Same thing.
Why would the life in general bna
different region to the applying the
scheme to everything that comes your
way?
I mean,
to me real talent is,
uh,
is mainly mobile to judge things.
I can hear them.
Fortunately the,
her little ear buds are picking up on
the,
uh,
the microphones.
Okay,
let's try it now.
Are you sure you don't want to watch TV?
That's ridiculous.
My kids watch tv every chance they get
because I don't want to watch tv so I
can always go.
Do you want to watch them to you?
Like it's a book that up?
Yeah.
This is the greatest thing ever for
travel,
man,
for travel.
You put on one of those things behind
the headset and people will go,
oh,
why do that?
Why not have your kids like,
have a conversation with?
She's fucking for that session.
Only last so long.
Right?
It's just like educational cartoons now.
Cartoons like teach them how to spell
and teach them and they can sing along
with it and learn phrases and words.
Do you have you ever heard of.
Well there's atheism obviously,
but there's a thing called atheism plus.
Have you heard of new towels?
New Religion.
It's A.
It's atheism plus a set of moral
guidelines.
I call it de.
This is what I call it because it's like
it's all be a good person,
but I just think that's De,
you know,
and maybe like when it comes to things
like racism and these sort of
discussions or homophobia or any,
any sort of discussion about inequality
or treating people in a very negative
way because of something that they can't
control their sexual orientation or the
way the skin they have,
what color they are,
what part of the world they're from.
I think anybody who's a good person sees
that in 2014 recognizes.
That's a fucked up way to think.
So these people,
this atheism plus thing,
they have like atheism.
So they're all saying there's no god,
there's No God,
but we want a set of moral guidelines to
live our lives by no sexual harassment
and sexual harassment and feminist
issues are big aspect of that.
It's mostly a lot of like really weak
men,
placating to a lot of like angry women
and they formed this group were they all
sort of get together and they have
conferences and they just die each other
to death.
They say Dah.
It's all the same shit.
It's like it's all shit that you should
already know,
like don't be racist,
don't sexually
harass women.
Absolutely don't rape.
Of course,
you know,
don't murder,
Duh.
You know,
like,
okay,
well how many times can we talk about
it?
Right?
I get a certain point.
I've watched a bunch of their
conferences online and it's hilarious
because it's so fucking pedantic at the
end of [inaudible] you get beaten to
death by what they're saying.
It's like you should already know this.
Everyone should know this.
This is,
this is silly.
And I think that depends on what
audience you're speaking to because you
know,
for anybody was as same id,
sane human being shrewd.
I've learned these by the time and our
five and it's like don and overweight
that are we still talking about it?
Then of course there are a bunch of
people that are not exactly same id
saying you won beings.
So maybe for those guys he's a good
message.
But I agree with you.
It's like to me,
my thing is like I use these diamond
time again in podcasts and writing.
I always write the whole idea that rules
are for people who are too stupid to
leave without the rules because you know
if you are smart you don't need them.
But it was because you know how to make
the right call in every situation and
you don't need anybody telling you,
look,
don't rape anybody.
It's like,
I don't need you to tell me.
I got it.
You know,
when you're in the situation,
I need the next thing.
The next.
No,
it's not gonna apply.
That's not that.
There's gonna be the exception to that
role either seeing,
they're going to be exceptions,
but steel.
You're going to have the intelligence to
be able to make the right call.
He's Ui or somebody was coming to Mug
me.
They made me punching your interface is
a good idea.
You are somebody who is disagreeing with
me punching in the face.
You're crazy.
We a social pet,
you know,
you don't need a rule paddle knew when
it's appropriate or not.
You know,
you,
you are able to make the right call that
Ben's.
Yeah,
and that's where he's freaking amazing
that you can carry on a conversation
with her squirming crawling on you.
This is not working nearly as well as we
were hoping it was going.
So it's a whole thing.
She was going to watch the television or
watch their little video or being,
you know,
cheaply.
Apologize.
No worries man.
I honestly thought that.
Yeah.
I also had higher hopes than,
uh,
than these.
Then again,
she's five painful.
It's,
yeah,
they just,
they are what they are five sometime,
you know,
she surprised me because she'll do
things that I'm like,
really?
How the hell it,
like I had this conversation with 30
other day where she's telling me,
um,
I don't like it,
that I'm so sensitive because every
little thing,
you know,
I feel every scene too much when I'm
happy,
I'm really happy when I'm sad.
I'm really sad and I'm like,
you have five already were having this
conversation and then she goes,
even one step forward or she goes,
but you know what?
It's okay because at least when I'm
happy I'm really super happy.
So I'll take the pain of when I'm really
sad thinking,
Jesus,
who are you again?
Let's try this.
So,
you know,
I get in those conversational when I'm
like,
wait,
you are way bigger than five.
I can take you to do this and that.
And then I realized,
no,
she's a five-year-old curve that are
limits to the game.
But well there's this understanding that
comes with being a human being and
that's what she's got.
She's just,
she's a human being with,
you know,
how am I,
what is it 100 months on the planet or
something like that,
you know,
there's lead me to not even imagine
trying to figure the world out with 100
months of experience and I mean a year
of school or whatever.
She's I possible,
but you do have that little human brain
and then you're also juggling around
this,
this collection of words that you've
acquired and so you're trying to express
these ideas and thoughts and feelings.
One of the themes that are coming out
with the boat there from the get go is
that she not exactly now because she's
not picking up on the frustration of it
all of the discussion,
but normally she has a seen a level of
empathy.
Not just for a kid,
but like even for adults.
I see her.
She's always,
whenever she sees somebody was having a
bad day,
it was really sad.
She instantly goes to them.
She's trying to,
like,
I've seen her at school where she'll go
to a kid was like,
hey,
he's in bed.
The kid that you don't like.
It was always giving you a hard time and
she's like,
yeah,
but I still feel bad to look at what a
bad day these guys and she's going to
like trying to call him for diamond to
this scene.
I'm like,
Jesus,
man,
you got a really nice nicer to me.
I thought maybe that's what it is.
Maybe they.
I definitely think kids recognize things
that their parents do that they don't
think of the right way to handle things.
Come up with their own sort of work
arounds.
It's pretty laborious either in school
where she was clearly quoting Bob Marley
liquid.
She was going through a phase where Bob
Marley was called Marley.
Yeah.
She goes,
I know she loved Bob Marley to death and
she would,
um,
she went to this key to us crying
because his mom had laughed and was like
in preschool or something.
She was four and she started robbing the
kids back as the cutesy.
And she say,
don't worry about thing.
I every little thing is going to be all
that.
I really felt burt's that's a lariat.
She'll ever own the.
We are seeing some that one day she's
like,
she asked me shooting the car and she
asked me for it immediately on time for
Bob Marley and I'm like,
okay,
no problem.
What Song do you want?
Like two little birds.
I'm like,
no baby,
it's three little birds.
He's like,
no.
I'm like,
what do you mean it's three?
No one got shot.
So now there's two little dirt and I'm
like,
she's,
that's morbid that really are going to
play today.
But yeah,
my daughter who's four,
keeps asking me to take her hunting.
Really?
Yeah.
And I don't know if she's serious or if
she misses me when I go away and she
wants to do like she's never heard a
gunshot.
You know,
there's,
I mean there's obviously no way she's
going to be a pullback in Arrow that's
strong enough to kill an animal.
So it's like that's not gonna happen.
No,
of course.
But step one would probably get used to
hearing gunshots.
I don't know.
She's just so bored.
That held me.
What's mad?
Tiny
pinch because you are driving me crazy
square.
He's settle down.
We can't put on a show for you or
something like that.
A television show for you to watch.
Yeah,
baby,
actually,
let's do this serious.
Sit down and watch your show because
unfortunately this is being seen by
thousands and heard by hundreds of
thousands.
The failing,
that's today's podcast about it at all.
Like I said,
it's,
you know,
that's one thing of becoming a father
and being around kids.
When I was really young,
like when I was in my early twenties,
I would never be able to deal with it.
Like little kids.
I'd be like,
ah,
the guy brought his little kid,
but like when I'm on a plane and like
little kids crying,
it doesn't bother me at all.
It used to drive me crazy,
but when you have kids,
it's one of those things where you kind
of recognize.
One of the things that happened,
the big shift that happened is I started
thinking of everyone as being a baby at
one point in time.
Like one point in time,
Kim Jong Il was a baby.
I know,
right?
That's fucked up.
You know,
like Edm.
He was a baby.
All these weird people in the world,
you know that fucking Pistorius guy that
shot his girlfriend throughout bathroom
door.
That guy was a baby.
Yep.
Okay.
You know all these creeps and fuck ups
and assholes.
Babies.
Gloria allred was a baby.
There was a cute little girl.
Now she's fucking Robin.
People using the law.
Just straight up rob dudes out much do
you think is how much do you believe in,
um,
whether it be dna or a soul or something
like something that's purely uniquely
about that person when they are born and
that's part of our car or our culture.
You're not a female's nurture versus
culture debate.
What?
What's your take on what's more
important in this?
I don't know.
Well,
they have done studies where they've
taken twins that were separated at birth
that were adopted and they get them
together after not seeing each other
entire life and they find out they liked
the same kind of music.
Really?
Yeah.
They,
they have very similar likes and
dislikes.
Their personalities are very similar.
There's a strong argument for nature
over nurture,
but there's no denying that nurture
plays a huge role as well.
I don't think it's either or.
I think we live in a soup of
possibilities and I think that you can
get super lucky with the amount of
exposure that you have to positive and
even to negative things like there's an
expression hard times make good people,
you know,
and I do believe that in a certain sense
that there's some experiences that
children and adults even have that they
get through and it makes them more
empathetic.
It makes them kinder,
make some more understanding and it
makes them stronger,
like more,
more character.
Even though it's funny because you're
right,
I mean there's part of that that's
totally true
and you do see that happen a lot and
then you see somebody who through the
exact same thing and it makes them 10
times more of an asshole.
I got hurt so I'm going to hurt anybody
else in the process and with them and
he's like that.
That's where you think like what is the
make these one person make a right turn
and going in their actual where they
become a kinder and nicer because they
felt what it is to get hurt and what is
the other one may make the complete
opposite turn and going in the direction
of I got hurt so I don't care for
anybody else.
This feeding,
everybody has to pay for defendant.
I go hurt once.
Yeah,
it's weird,
right?
It's like there's that moment where you
can really make a 90 degree turn one way
or another.
What is the make people make the choices
they make?
It's a very good question and it could
be a lot of it could be genetics.
I mean their epigenetics,
that the concept that people are passing
down ideas through their DNA to their
children is,
is not without merit.
The idea that your ideas that the
lessons you've learned in your life are
not just stored in your brain but are
stored in every cell in your body and
also stored in your genetic material
that passes on to your woman who gives
birth to the baby and the baby has the
genetic material from both the mother
and the father.
I mean all of that is is real stuff,
man.
All absolute real possibilities and it's
really incredibly fascinating.
The idea that we are this soup of
possibilities.
We do exist in this very strange world
of so many different things going on at
the same time
and there is something to.
Yeah,
you're right,
because that's the experience part of it
all where you got some kind of traumatic
experience that really changes your,
your makeup the way you are as a,
as a person,
as a human being and like.
And at that point to kind.
I mean I've seen even on myself not I'm
dealing with right now.
I see how my brain has changed over the
last 30,
40 years in some ways,
you know,
go the way.
In some ways really not in a good way.
What way is in a bad way.
I think I do have.
I didn't think so,
but now I'm coming to the realization
that I do have some serious ptsd,
you know,
we're seeing,
my wife died in my arms,
wasn't quite as a,
Oh,
I can deal with dates.
Sure.
Rationally understand us.
She tap ins and nobody's seen goes.
But it did affect me to a different
level.
So I know I'd have to give you an
example.
I'll see that because of the way it
started with there.
He's like,
when she got sick in the first scene,
that was,
it was like a tiny little thing.
It's like,
oh,
my shoulder hurts.
He's like a big deal,
right?
It's like,
well,
you went to the gym and you lift it too
much.
Whatever.
Something seeing that transformed me and
I met throw for weeks to,
Oh man,
I can't move my arm anymore.
Oh,
I can barely walk that.
All of that in such a short period of
time.
Now,
every time there's something wrong with
my body,
I don't just think like,
oh,
look at that weird little scene to them
that I'm having my mind immediately
erased the whole sequence and I'm like,
I'm going to die tomorrow.
Some horrible,
terrible disease.
Anything.
I know better.
Reich noted that stupid.
And I know that that's a fantasy.
That's like puddle Jack Things,
things that are definitely not lpn and
if anything they are damaging and I
still can't help it.
They're still part of my brain that even
the conscious of the.
I know it's stupid.
I still go there every single time.
There's something wrong with my body.
And so he's like,
man,
what do I need to do to change that?
You know,
because he's almost like Pavlov's dogs,
right?
Is Conditional response is immediately
the second something goes,
they're piled high,
go with it.
And uh,
and you know,
there are moments where I have control
over it and I can kind of come to this
place.
That's because I've seen horrible things
can happen at any moment.
I actually try and sign and date and I'm
like,
look,
you have no control over anything,
so let's have fun right here,
right now because what the hell knows
what happened tomorrow?
That's the empowering part of it and I
love it when I get that and I don't love
so much.
And the other one,
which is that terror of,
Oh shit,
something's gonna happen.
Which you know,
inevitably something's going to happen
at some point,
right?
I mean,
everybody dies,
everybody gets sick.
That's just the nature of the business.
But having that in the back of your mind
as a some time paralyzing thought,
that's a whole different game.
That's part of the problem with being a
human being,
isn't it?
You're the awareness,
the awareness of your,
the finite nature of your existence and
the fact that it's coming,
whether it's tomorrow or 100 years from
now,
it's coming.
You know,
if you told someone that they're going
to die in a thousand years,
I still freak out.
Of course,
every year passes 999
pithily and I mean that's just the
noise,
but there's a somewhat removed,
right?
There's that intellectual,
existential anxiety and then there's
existential anxiety or for sort of like
people who have seen the weather because
of war or sickness or whatever.
People close to them die in horrible
ways.
It's not just an intellectual.
Some point in the future or something
bad is going happen is it's in the past,
something bad is gonna happen in any
second now can app and that's not a fun
way.
No,
it's not the best way.
It's not.
It's not good in any sense of the word.
Living in the moment and being happy in
the moment is very.
It's a.
it's a very difficult thing to do.
It requires.
It requires discipline and it also
requires that you develop like a pattern
of thinking.
Yep,
and you didn't get.
That's one of the things we were talking
about with the young people,
like they automatically start blaming
the world and hating on people for
whatever has happened wrong to them to
make people feel the way.
I feel that there's patterns of thinking
that you can fall into like almost
automatically and once you have that
pattern,
it's a cut groove and that groove is
very easy to slip into.
It's very comfortable.
It's very simple.
One of the things that psychedelics do
is pull you out of that groove.
Exactly.
They,
they lift you above the motherboard and
you get to see what the groove is.
Oh,
this is just a pattern that I've created
and it doesn't.
Not only is not empowering,
it doesn't even make sense.
I'm going to live my life a fucking
disaster.
I'm going to 60 more years of this.
Then my heart's going to stop beating
and I'm going to die an asshole that's
very easy to fall into.
It's very easy.
It can happen to all of us if I go.
Oh,
sorry,
go ahead.
I was just going to say it's very hard
to reset and even when you do reset,
it's hard to continue that new pattern.
It's like it requires great discipline
and sometimes you've got to write things
down.
Writing things down is big right now.
Writing things down,
reading things,
positive affirmations.
Nobody likes the idea that you go over
someone's house and they have fucking
all these things written on the walls,
like today's a new day today.
We're going to go forth with strength
and dignity,
but doing stuff like that actually can
benefit you.
It can,
it can.
Writing things on walls and you know,
having positive affirmations can help
you.
Yeah,
because I mean some stuff,
just because you know,
it doesn't mean that you don't need to
hear it again and again,
realize it because you know,
most people know if you have read the
books,
if you have been alive long enough,
you probably know what's there is to
know you've already before.
The difference is transforming deaf from
intellectual knowledge into actual.
It's part of your being part of
something that affects how you behave.
Both the old buddy and I'm amber Lyon on
giving me the lecture about psychedelics
moved three times now regarding the,
this is what you need to now.
It's a fascinating case,
boys.
She has.
I've never met anybody that I gave the
suggestions to like I gave to her where
they just fucking ran with it.
Like she did that she had changed her
life.
Henneberry's it three,
she's a trip.
I didn't meet her before,
so I don't know what the before looked
like.
Yeah,
before she was a very rational,
serious journalist who was very
concerned about the future of humanity
and our culture and in journalism
because she had seen the ugly side of
the beast where she had reported on some
horrific events in Bahrain and when she
got back and try to put together the CNN
piece,
they instead put out this fluff piece,
like almost like a tourism propaganda
video for Bahrain,
Bahrain,
depending on how you set.
Um,
but then when I talked to her about
Iowasca,
which by the way,
I've never even done.
I totally go do Iowaska.
That was the funniest thing of that
started at time.
Berkeley House.
He's like John Globe about the down it.
And they say,
you know,
that Joe never did right?
She's like,
yeah,
but I've done dmt a dozen times,
at least.
Probably nine,
10 or 12,
something like that.
But this the same thing.
I mean,
it's,
it isn't,
but it is.
I mean,
it's the same psychoactive substance.
In fact,
DMT,
the small global forum is a stronger
version of a Iowasca,
but I asked.
It tends to be a long spiritual trip,
which I thought would really benefit
her.
You know,
that she was struggling it.
Right.
And it sure did.
I mean,
again,
I,
I haven't seen them before.
By the after is insane.
I mean seriously one of those people
that she glows every time I out with
her,
I feel happier.
She's,
she's a drug.
You know what I mean?
Is like in the same room,
improve the level of fat is I'm amazed
by her every time.
I'm just like,
are you for real?
I'm like,
I have never.
I can think of too many people that I've
met that are that happy while she's
doing psychedelics,
every couple of months I was fucking hit
it so hard from the moment I met her,
like I guess it was like two plus years
ago,
more than two years ago because we
didn't have the studio.
So from that moment on,
when she went to the job,
she went to the jungle like a fucking
month after I brought her up,
maybe even less went.
And even though they told her I didn't,
had never done I was,
she's still fucking,
um,
I think I knew that I told her to do it
and I knew that it was the thing that
she needed.
Some people really need that they need
to go to a place and they need to
experience this thing in this very alien
form.
And it's so transformative because of
the fact that you're in that place,
you know?
I mean,
I'm sure I could probably benefit from
it,
but my,
what I like to do,
I mean,
my thing,
I have a sensory deprivation tank in my
basement,
so I'm,
I'm,
I'm sort of experiencing is as removed
as the jungle might be.
I'm removing myself from reality itself
on this daily basis.
Not to say that I wouldn't still benefit
from it,
but I wouldn't subscribe what I do.
Right.
You know,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't prescribe rather.
I wouldn't say what you need to do is
get a tank filled up with water and he'd
trip your fucking balls out and climbing
that thing.
Like,
I'm not doing that right now.
I have friends that come over.
They don't want to do the tank.
Like I'm going to get in there.
Why?
What's so scary about it?
I mean,
reality is that fucking thing.
Oh,
because the big fucking meat locker of
reality and I need to do to that have
done it.
I mean,
I've always liked.
I always felt great or no.
Yeah.
Maybe that's my mistake.
Have you been sober?
Yeah,
I remember the first time.
It was good to do it sober,
you know,
amateur,
right?
Gotcha.
Sure.
Float tank,
uh,
with an asterisk.
The asterisk is very important because
whatever the asked Rick can do the astro
can do in regular life.
It's multiplied 10 fold inside of there
because especially edibles,
edible marijuana becomes a full blown
psychedelic experiments and the that he
bolts for somebody who is like 11
hydroxy metabolite.
That's what it is.
Maybe that's the [inaudible] I've tried.
Every time I've tried edibles is either
too little where I don't feel it or I
feel like somebody grabbing the biggest
basketball back in,
but your way first and just slagged me
off.
Not Pleasurable.
Just like,
oh my God,
where am I?
What the hell?
Those are my favorite trips really does.
We'll do.
I don't think them whether it happened
when they were over,
I learned the most from them.
Like I like being scared that because I
know
I'm going to be okay,
but I don't know.
I'm going to be okay.
Why it's happening.
I think I got when I was maybe 15 or 16,
something like that.
I did this.
I remember making these tea with ashish
and the.
We got a little carried away because
they were supposed to be a bunch of
people doing that and it turned out to
be only two or five years.
So the doors that were supposed to be
for like,
I think he was like half a gram per
person and the study was two and a half
a gram per person.
That's a lot.
So by the time we'd down it's,
you know,
an hour goes by with teddy bowls is also
messy because you don't feel it right
away.
So an hour goes by and you're like,
Eh,
nothing happening.
Two hours goes by.
I'm like,
really?
Nothing steal.
What a waste.
We throw that stuff away.
I go to sleep,
I wake up two hours later and I'm just
like,
am I?
Where am I?
And I pass out and I opened up my eyes
again and like,
where am I?
And I,
and the next six hours go like these
where I basically lose consciousness 70,
30 seconds and I wake up,
where am I?
Or Am I think after that I was like,
yeah,
I don't think I'm doing too badly.
It even other times that I've done it
was always not quite that bad,
but clothes.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I don't think it bolts are,
are men for me.
Well,
there's,
there's so many religions that have
cannabis and cannabis eating as the base
of their religion.
Hindu is,
um,
there's so many,
uh,
so many passages in,
in ancient Hindu scripts.
And I'm like,
if you look up,
if you look up on,
on,
uh,
on Wikipedia,
you can look up the f entheogenic use of
cannabis and shows all these different
times where people have used cannabis as
a psychedelic,
like not just,
Oh,
we're smoking a joint relaxed,
but when you eat it,
you have these profound visions,
but you eat enough.
Like Mckenna used to say that eating
like large doses of marijuana was
equivalent to eating large doses of
mushrooms.
It's just a matter of having the courage
to eat too much code.
You'll never get the crazy heart fast
heart rate on a,
on edibles.
You can.
Yeah.
Because then you don't get a fast heart
rate,
but you get this panic sense like I'm
never going to sober up.
Oh,
but not as a physical thing.
A physical thing like I've done like a
heart.
Yeah.
Where I feel my heart start pounding
where I'm just like,
Jesus,
I'm going like 120 beats per minute with
our son seeing which are not doing
exercise.
That's a bit much.
I bet it's anxiety.
That probably as probably is because it
brings on a lot of anxiety.
Oh yeah.
Heavy duty edibles make you really
reconsider it.
It's,
it's very difficult to live in the
moment on heavy duty edibles because it
forces you to examine problematic
aspects of your past behavior,
assuming you'll still have an affluent
cdt because there are really tight.
So I'm just like,
I'm not accepting,
not accepting a belief.
I don't know.
Well,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
You can go too deep.
Not too long ago with the Rick Simpson
oil.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Which supposed to be great for health
and then you know,
the thing with the oil is that unless
somebody preparing it for you in
capsules or something,
it's such a guesswork of trying to
figure out which one is how many drops
you not put up.
Yeah.
So I've done it where I take a tiny bit
and I feel nothing and I'm assuming it's
Ilt,
but whatever.
I'm not feeling anything and I take a
tiny bit and one day I take a tiny beat
plus a,
my new school,
tiny micro drop more and I'm like
hitting the trees.
Right.
I'm just way out there and I'm like,
whoa.
What's also,
who's making those things know being
made in the same place where they make
Tesla's?
Yeah,
that's part of the problem when that's
why we did sell feudal.
Well,
it's the plan.
You can kind of figure things out and
when you're smoking it you can sort of
feel how it's going and you can stop.
It's edible,
sees you take it and an hour later
you're in Florida.
Surprise to see what it's like.
I was listening to this radio show the
other day where people are complaining
about marijuana being stronger than it
was when they were kids.
Like this guy in his fifties who just
recently tried marijuana again and he
was talking about how he overdosed.
I overdosed on marijuana and I swear to
God,
how do you exactly.
You almost went to the hospital.
I mean I barely got through it.
I mean you can overdose.
I mean it was like going on like about
the pot today,
right?
It's dangerous.
Like shut the fuck up.
What do you like?
The fact that someone can go on the air
and say something like that,
that's bullshit.
It's what's it's.
It's not just like you could put a bad
thought in someone's head and I really
believe that they could die from it
unless they have a computer people.
I'm talking from zero,
zero
ever.
No,
never.
I'm going to be the first one.
The first one to die.
I'm going to fuck it all up for
everybody else.
I want to be the first one to die.
Right?
There was a guy who died in Colorado
because he jumped off a roof and they
were trying to get rid of edibles
because in one fucking dipshit jumped
off a roof.
The thing is,
every single substance that's out there
is even the mosque held water.
If you drink too much water,
you can die from it.
Right?
I mean,
he's like every single
using gay too.
What's the con?
Every tool.
Cars,
everything,
skateboards.
Everything is how you lose it.
I mean if we,
if we based what kills you,
you know what's illegal?
We would literally make everything
illegal.
Yeah.
It'll be number one.
People have died from using computer,
computers are blown up on people and
they've died.
Right?
Cell phones have blown up in people's
pockets and they've been gravely injured
or died from a cell phone.
Let's find out.
Let's sound good.
Anyways,
killed by cell phones.
I'm going to say yes.
I'm going to say killed by cell phone.
While you're finding out about the cell
phone,
let me take care of them.
Tiny monkey.
Okay.
Don't answer the call while charging.
Urban legends man takes woman's cell
phone after she's killed by train.
Wow,
that's dark man.
Killed by cell phone explosion.
Okay.
Let's see.
Gizmodo man killed by cell phone
explosion.
A Korean man was apparently killed by
his LG cell phone today and this was a,
by the way,
in 2007,
they probably got old shit back then.
He was carrying the phone in his shirt
pocket when it exploded,
puncturing his heart and lungs.
It happened in North Chung Cheong
Province of Korea.
As the man was working on a construction
site,
he was found dead by one of his
coworkers.
Whoa.
Do you think his parents or his family
got some money?
Wendy's.
This was North Korea now South Korea.
Korea says a Korean man.
North Chung Chung.
It's just just as Korea.
It doesn't say North or South Korea.
I'm assuming it's South Korea because
North Korea,
I think there are about 250 to six years
away from seeing cell phones.
Yeah,
this is.
no kidding.
Right.
Poor bastards.
That's why the one of the craziest
things about 2014 that we still have a
real live communist dictator running and
entire country.
That's terrified.
Yep.
I this little goofy,
Chubby moon face motherfucker.
Who's the son of another goofy Chelsie
moon face motherfucker.
It's like that just.
Yeah.
Or the Isis Guy.
I mean sinks that really belong to the
Middle Ages.
Then you're like really dwindled shit.
Come on.
This is where.
And on one end,
you know,
you see humanity and we are so damn
advanced and we are doing these amazing
things.
And on the other end where dwayne steel,
the same sheets that were Dwayne 2000
years ago,
those isis guys are.
They release videos on youtube to
graphic horrific videos on youtube and
then they don't get pulled.
Yeah.
Until like weeks later he find out about
them like,
I don't know how like a video gets
pulled from youtube.
I mean someone has to flag it I guess.
Yeah.
And like maybe they're only sending it
to the people that they know or,
or whatever and they'll survive a while
before but somebody put something up
like check this shit out.
And I went and clicked on a link and I
was like,
Jesus,
this is on Youtube.
I know these guys shooting each other,
these shooting these guys while they
were on the ground and then cutting
their heads off like all very,
very graphic.
And I was like,
I can't believe this is on Youtube.
There's stuff out there that makes you.
I've seen the most disturbing things
I've ever seen was this one thing he
like somewhere in Africa or somebody
suspected of being anxious and so they
get of these people and set them on fire
and you know,
after awhile I was like,
you know,
why the hell am I watching this done
over?
I know that Ben,
so I don't need to see it in it's nuts.
It's like straight out of the 39 minutes
or something in 2014 is all the progress
that we've gone through to get to this
point in age and there's still some
people that just.
You could take them,
you could shove them back to the year
zero and they would fit called.
Yes.
Yeah,
it's both.
It's.
There's that thing going on.
Human beings,
man,
that spectrum.
The broad spectrum of behavior where it
almost seems like you have to have like
shitty people to appreciate the good
people.
Like I wonder if there's ever going to
come a time where there's a legitimate
biological utopia where like human
beings like where they achieve some form
of enlightenment where everyone has
reached the dust age.
We're talking about like his atheism,
plus they rattle this onto themselves,
but they should know better.
They're all fucking educated and going
to conferences and stuff like that.
They see.
It's like they're preaching to the choir
essentially or,
or propping themselves up on a nice
moral high ground in front of their
peers.
But there's gonna come a time where the
whole world is like that.
Is that possible?
That would be an an I get what you're
saying about you need the bad people to
their shade.
The good people.
There's a general improvement of
humanity going into more pleasant
direction.
We don't need the bad people just give
us a dvds,
a showing
this is what the bad people experiences
like.
Whoa.
Really?
And you know,
make people very nice.
So you watch movies and you get almost
like an experience
without diving actually to deal with it
because the whole restaurant,
now that you've been here,
a religious devout are.
You need to evolve in order to
appreciate the good.
Like to what degree man,
because we talk about human history,
there has been so much evil that is like
really?
I could actually do with one,
100 of that.
I will learn the lesson.
I don't need to learn that same lesson
over and over again in such brutal nasty
fashion.
There's something about the design of
human history or nature or for that
matter,
because as you say multiple times.
I mean,
when you look at nature,
it's like it's not a soft,
fuzzy,
happy animals running around the forest.
He's brutal.
His fangs and close on the whole thing
and it's like,
yeah,
maybe if it's about appreciating the
good stuff,
there would be a gentler way to go about
it.
Do we really have to go these hardcore?
It will make it happen.
Yeah.
Nature is the most vicious motherfucker.
A wall my friend was telling me about,
I'm watching this bear killed this
female bear.
He was watching his grizzly bears.
They were observing them and this male
was trying to mate with this female
grizzly bear and the grizzly bear.
I didn't want to mate with them.
She kept pushing them off and yelling at
him.
I kept trying so hard to get her to meet
with them,
but she didn't want to do it and then a
new grizzly bear,
a new female came into the picture and
the new female came into the picture and
started trying to get him to meet with
her and he got angry that she was
distracting him so he murdered her in
front of the other business.
Just tore her apart,
that just ripped her to shreds and he
said it was the craziest thing because
all of a sudden this bear had its feet
up in the air and it was just dead like
within seconds,
like a few seconds ago,
it had wandered into the camp,
you know,
or into this little valley with these
were and tried to get this bear to me
and he,
he's a biologist and so he was observing
this stuff or if he's not a biologist
who works with biologists and it was
observing this stuff and he said it was
one of the most disturbing things he's
ever seen in his life.
He's a hunter.
He's lived his whole life hunting and
you know,
death is a normal,
natural part of life to him.
But this to him freaked him out more
than anything I'd ever seen because he
said it was so brutal and it was so
instantaneous,
you know,
it's just really crazy,
man.
Do you ever do divert daily about the
rapists,
necrophilia docs,
docs?
I didn't tell you about the rapists
necrophilia docs thing.
So I have to.
So,
you know,
cute little dogs,
they are adorable.
I remember seeing docs beam bar naturing
out with an ag and I'm like,
I never eat in Nag again.
Diane 18 doc again and poorly told that,
you know,
you got into these romanticized cute
fuzzy thing.
Right?
And then I start reading about docs that
apparently mailed docs are particularly
fond of raping female dogs and um,
but this is where it gets interesting.
So they go out,
I'm sure maybe you've seen them in these
super high speed chase where the female
is that I need and there's like two or
three male run flying right behind her
and in,
during this high speed chases,
occasionally the female take the wrong
turn and she ask us into something a
three or a weekend or something.
And then she,
uh,
she broke her neck and die immediately.
But you know,
bodies still warm.
So the one that'd be rapists,
docs on poor suites,
the side,
ah,
what the hell,
we don't want to waste this.
So.
And they just got on and have sex with a
dead corpse after that.
I'm like,
docs are back on the manual
motherfuckers because you guys are mean
and horrible and I'm going to each
again,
maybe this is show to all those people
that are trying to keep you from eating
fog war,
right.
You know,
that's a weird thing that California
has.
California has a law where you're not
allowed to eat duck liver,
but you can eat ducks because they were
forced feeding these ducks if their
liver to grow and people found out to be
unbelievably cruel,
I guess crueler than killing them.
Right.
And eating them like force feeding them
to get their livers to grow larger was
crueler than killing them.
Emi.
Okay.
I mean the,
you know,
the stuff that's done in raising
anymore,
letting industrial level tend to be
pretty fucked up,
which is why even people who whine about
that but they do anything related to
whether you have land that already with
any kind of meat is ridiculous because
it's like hunting is a lot cleaner.
That way.
You know,
you'll let the animal live its life be
for the end of every single commercial
farming.
Yet,
there's some nasty stuff happening at
the same time,
you know,
there are limits to how far you want to
take it because there's.
They're not too many simple,
clean,
painless,
easy ways to do seeing that still
deliver the goods that people that rely
on.
So it's a very.
That's why he's the same thing as the
stuff we were saying earlier.
Any kind of dogmatic position about
these either the scuttle animals,
they're just here for us to use an Okr
sweater and
a software horribly or the poor little
band.
Nice.
You can touch anything.
I've missed the boat.
Three colors,
right?
They both have a point that they are
both ridiculous.
If taken too far.
Have you ever seen the video of a woman?
She walks into a restaurant and tells
everyone in the restaurant that what
they're eating is not food.
It's violence.
No,
and she.
She goes in,
she tells everybody about her little
girl.
I want to tell you about my little girl
and it's chicken.
She's talking about.
Her name is snow.
Have you seen it?
We've seen it.
Jamie,
let me find it for you.
We should play it because it's just so
ridiculous.
No,
that's not food.
It's violence.
Are you done kid?
We can.
We can end this and next time you come
by I'll bring my daughter the otters and
we'll have a little party.
They complain and rant goes viral.
This isn't food.
It's violence.
Pull this up and we'll have you seen
with bill cosby did yesterday.
There was just that right before we
started.
Lord,
if you don't know what's going on about
bill cosby,
Bill cosby going to be very careful how
I phrase this.
Allegedly has raped a large number of
women and allegedly has drug these women
and I mean I find it hard to believe
that 13 women would make something
that's a large number.
I mean it would have to be some massive
conspiracy dating back to the 19
seventies just now being uncovered.
So he put this thing on his website
yesterday,
like me.
Go ahead and meme me with a photo of him
and the meme being the print that you
can add a meme generator and his said,
happy Monday and these people just went
crazy.
I mean it,
it went,
it got so ugly,
like,
I mean one of them was like,
one of the first one was like more than
a dozen women have accused me of rape.
How can I hear you say no because he's
got like headphones on.
What do you mean you're pressing
charges?
I mean it's,
it's,
these are the mild ones,
but I mean,
what was he thinking?
He's a fucking idiot.
What the hell was he thinking for?
A lot of people believe that someone who
works for him did it on purpose.
Really.
Someone who works for him knew that it
was going to like someone who is like a
website designer.
We've got to think like website
designers.
A lot of times younger people and maybe
even a woman.
Right?
You know,
it was like this fucking piece of shit.
I can't believe I'm working for him.
Or a guy who is sympathetic to what's
going on and says,
look,
how do I get this fucker that would
actually be ged?
That's what happened.
That's great.
I mean they put a bunch of them that
were like really cute.
His on his website,
like they,
they took some of the ones that people
had created that were pg rated,
but the amount that were raped related
was so staggering.
Well,
of course.
I mean,
what's he like in the news?
What's has been like,
what have you heard about him in the
news over the last year has been the
story,
right?
So it's like,
of course that's what's going to pop up.
Of course that's what's going to happen
and no one is a press charges is okay.
I wonder how you could.
Because it's.
It seems strange,
you know,
it seems like if you don't have the
physical evidence like,
but you have 13 people telling a similar
story.
I wonder how that works.
The pencils are from how long ago it is
because that's all statue of
limitations.
Is there a statute of limitations on
rape?
I'm as it and I think it is.
I think it is.
I think there is,
isn't that would save that 77 guy.
That's exactly what it is.
Right?
This is a statute of limitations is
wiser.
Central limitations on something so
horrible.
Know.
It becomes tricky though because of
course once you wait to report it,
it's all physical evidence is gone and
Danny,
you have to rely on a lot the newer kind
of evidence that's a lot harder to make
the case.
There is also that.
The thing about memory right discussed
earlier that human memory is one of the
worst pieces of evidence you could ever
get.
There are people that I have had
experiences with where they'll go,
hey,
remember when we did this and did that
and blah blah,
blah.
I'm like,
we never even been in there with,
you know,
you went with us like,
listen man,
I've never been to South Dakota.
Stop.
It didn't happen.
Or they remember the wrong state or
there.
I mean,
people's memories are fucking terrible.
They're awful.
Do you have this video will play this
and then we'll give her a chance.
Slicker.
She looks,
she's done.
We did like an hour and a half.
That's all good.
Like you got to see this.
Watch this video.
Please put your headphones on so you can
hear this stuff,
but it's not plugged in anymore.
So you of course,
hold on a second,
give it a chance.
Did she yank it out?
Of course.
It's like,
okay,
we'll just play this and then we'll end
it.
This is so ridiculous.
This woman walks in this restaurant and
there there's a whole group of people
behind her.
She walked into a restaurant and people
are eating little girl.
She was very abused for her entire life.
She was terrified.
She has a very determined look in her
eyes wherever she goes,
and she was hurt and abused her entire
life because of this establishment and
because of establishment,
she was locked away.
She was hidden.
She got nobody there for her.
She was crying.
She was scared every single moment and
because they're useful as had run out,
she was going to be killed.
Someone to blame and I can.
I can see you laughing.
It's not funny.
I went in there with other humans.
I took her out of there.
She wouldn't be with me right now.
She wouldn't be gone just like,
all right everybody today.
There was other girls,
but they just wanted to live their life
and their bodies and every time you see
someone eating somebody else's ags or
somebody else's body,
you are going to remember her name.
Her name is a beautiful little girl and
it didn't just violent is the best part.
They all come in and they all have a
sign like it's not just to say it.
They have to have assigned it.
Hold on.
I think of her name every time,
like these fucking pathetic people that
are just so lucky.
Their ancestors ate meat to get them to
2014 idealistic little kids in this
video that you have the in the
background.
Say,
my girl is all perfect,
but it's crazy.
She has this determined look in her
eyes.
She goes,
no,
she doesn't.
Okay.
Her expression never changed.
She's a fucking chicken.
God dammit and crazy lady.
That is one of my favorite videos ever
because she's just so bonkers.
Like I see you smiling.
Gee,
I wonder why we're smiling.
Maybe because you're kind of crazy.
You're walking into a chicken restaurant
with more people and Jamie's right.
There's more people came with her that
were in the restaurant.
What's the at like two in the afternoon
and some flower.
It was just so strange.
She's a little girl,
just turban looking her wherever she
goes and she just went to live and
people are eating her eggs.
I guess what?
I eat my chicken's eggs and they don't
care at all.
You know why?
Because the eggs don't become a chicken.
You fucking dunce.
Yeah.
He just eggs.
When you have chickens,
you can have chickens as pets.
They provide you with free protein,
right?
You give them food and they give you
protein.
That doesn't hurt anybody.
It doesn't harm them.
They have chickens.
They lay eggs every day.
Right.
This idea that you're their milk.
No,
no,
no.
There's no chicken meal.
Never seem to stay away from me.
They don't breastfeed,
but this,
you know,
that is the spectrum.
That's the spectrum.
I mean,
sensitivity is important and
understanding of nature's important.
I mean I've been accused,
especially lately since I've last couple
of years since I started hunting of
being cruel of doing it because you
enjoy killing animals.
I don't at all,
I mean I,
I enjoy hunting,
I enjoy bringing home the meat.
I actually,
I think that the killing of the animals,
the worst part of it,
the,
the fact that you're able to take an
animal out of nature though,
like in the most natural environment,
possibly if I didn't exist,
that animal would be doing the exact
same thing until I came along.
There was no influence whatsoever on its
life and then all sudden boom,
it ends,
which is going to end by wolves.
It's going to end by,
especially where I was,
I was up in Canada where they have,
they have so many wolves up there.
They have no limit on how many wolves
you can shoot serious that had begun to
wealth football,
a huge population problem.
Huge.
Like they have elk,
they have deer,
they have moose and the wolves are just
killing them left and right.
While we were up there and we actually
came upon,
we saw all these ravens that were
floating around this one area,
so we're trying to figure out what it
was that they were attracted to.
So we went over to it and we found this
moose calf that had been torn apart by
wolves.
This is the Moose calf.
I'll put it up on my instagram later so
you guys could see because you're not
going much left.
But this,
oh,
it's just mangled.
It was crazy and it was wolves,
wolves,
it taking it from,
from its mother.
And they just figured out a way to get
ahold of it and just ripped apart.
Cars,
devoured it,
and it was hair all over the ground.
Everything.
That's the reality of that life,
the get it.
And then what's left?
The coyotes get that and then what's
left,
you know,
any other scavengers get that.
That is a much more likely death.
And by hunter,
the hunter death is the least likely.
Yep,
absolutely.
And in that sense,
again,
to me it's like everything is going to
die as long as they are not doing where
you are wiping out with a species and as
long as they are not doing where you are
at Dean and necessity pain to the
process,
then that's the nature of the business.
Well,
what this woman is doing by running into
that restaurant and say it's not food,
it's violence,
like you're kind of.
You're missing the whole point.
You're missing the boat.
It's not violence.
It's ending life so that you could eat
it and yeah,
it's kind of a crazy way to do it
because we're detached from it.
You're,
you're right about that.
But again,
that's like a shitty communication
strategy because I'm sure she can have a
point where she's at it because there
are issues that we.
Commercial farming that are nasty,
terrible,
but you know,
there's a way to communicate it to where
you are.
I would be like,
oh,
you're right.
You'll make a good point.
So maybe we can tweak the lows.
A tiny beat to do it in a more humane
way.
Thought that they agree.
You go like these are preaching to the
choir.
You only have like pan out there.
People who feel the exact same way.
You do agree with you.
Even if somebody is 80 percent,
the other way you'll get are going to
look at you and go like,
Whoa,
you really went off the deep end.
She's emotionally unbalanced and on top
of that,
that leads people to want to kill more
chickens.
It really does.
I mean I have this guy that I'm friends
with up in Alaska or in BC rather,
that runs this hunting camp and he would
get these death threats from people
because they would be hunting wolves and
the reason why they hunt wolves,
they had one of their cows torn apart by
wolves.
These 30 wolves got ahold of a cow and
ripped it apart while the people were in
the house and their hand.
They look out the window and they see
this wolves bringing down a cow and
kill.
That is crazy stuff,
man.
Do to look out your window and see this
2000 pound animal get taken out by this
pack of wild,
murderous animals.
It's pretty.
It's got to be pretty cool,
but also pretty goddamn terrifying that
fans and people do get killed by wolves
and they certainly did in large numbers
back in the day,
which is why the Little Red Riding Hood,
the big bad wolf.
We don't think about that today because
it's not an issue,
but there was many,
many times throughout history where
wolves and killed people,
if you google like wolf desk by people
before we had eradicated like large
populations of the wolves,
there was actually a ceasefire in world
war one.
Remember that story?
Yeah.
The Germans,
the Germans and the Russians actually
called a ceasefire because so many of
them were getting killed by wolves.
They said,
all right,
let's just stop killing each other.
Fuck these wolves up real bad.
We couldn't go back to kill each other.
That's how nutty wolves are.
So these,
these people were sending this guy death
threats,
and he said,
every time you send me a death threat,
I'm going to shoot a wolf in the guts,
and so they stopped sending death
threats,
not just stopped posting.
This woman was like,
I'm going to post a new page every day
if you banned me,
I'm going to make a new name.
And he goes,
okay.
Every time you do that,
I'm gonna.
Shoot a wolf in the guts.
Silence.
Yeah.
I figured that the care of business
really is a way of communicating where
he's just like,
you think it's fun,
doesn't she thinks it's fun shooting the
gun so far.
I mean there's really a way to
communicate to the guests of the job is
like most people like to communicate and
preach to the choir kind of way.
Most people communicate in a way that's
not going to see that anywhere you are
coming from the person they are talking
with.
They're only considering where they are
coming through them and they want you to
feel what they're feeling,
what they're thinking.
Exactly.
Only they want to force their ideology
on you and in that sense like veganism
and vegetarianism is sort of a religion.
Just like we're talking about atheism
plus as a religion.
So is being a Christian and so is being
a mormon and you know,
it's like its ideology.
It's all.
It's all thought processes.
We,
you could label it and call it a
religion.
You could label it,
you know,
call it a cult.
You could call it whatever you want,
but it's just thought processes,
thought patterns that you want other
people to think.
You don't want them to express
themselves and you can look at it from
their point of view.
No,
you just want.
You want them to know and you're right,
this is not.
Food is violence.
No,
it's food.
It actually is food.
It's fucking chicken and I'm about to
eat and you.
You crazy bitch.
You came in with all these meek fucking
low blood sugar freaks holding up signs
thinking you got to change the world.
Changing Shit.
Go get a job.
What are you guys doing here at 2:00
in the afternoon?
How are you feeding yourself?
Do you have jobs?
What are you doing?
Your fucking parents are putting you
through schools that was going on here
and the thing there is like our many
people's minds have you just changed by
doing zero,
zero point zero.
So he's like,
even if you believe that you're 100
percent right in your message,
go back to the drawing board and look at
that.
What you just did is bullshit because it
doesn't lead to any single person being
convinced,
so figure out a better communication
strategy because you suck.
Yeah.
She needs to get on some IOWASCA.
Fucking elves would let her know.
Chickens are going to die no matter
what.
Bitch.
Yeah.
I.
Last time I did DMT,
I asked them about hunting.
I asked it and I'm like,
okay,
whatever.
That's literally what they said went
into,
and I had this thought in my head.
I was like,
uh,
his,
his hunting and is it,
is it morally acceptable?
Is there anything wrong with hunting?
And they're like,
it's fine.
Of course they're like,
they're like showing me all these
different things about life.
Like,
look,
you're going to die,
dies.
Everything dies.
It all goes into this thing and they're
showing me all these fractal reality and
I felt silly for asking that question
that I have to tell you about that.
My one and only dmt experience,
which is pretty fun because I did it
with Duncan Duncan.
He's hating it.
Then he's like seeing God and the
universe said he has these big smile on
his face and he's just like,
it's an I'm just like,
I'm looking at him and I think you are
the goofiest buster I've ever seen.
Doesn't just laughing my ass off,
but I've not seen have him to seem and I
keep hitting it.
So like there should be an at one point
I think,
whoa,
my perception is changing.
I am beginning to a vision because they
see that Duncan ceiling is all warped
and weird and then eventually come down
from the experience and I realize that
Dunkin is really just weird that it
wasn't working.
I was working in the sense that he was
like the biggest,
uh,
it was like the biggest weed,
the high in the universe.
I had the big body high,
you know,
I felt it really sinking into the couch
and melting into the couch and I failed
it.
That like every thing was hilarious,
but I did not have a fish.
Nope.
No one.
And you know,
I took as much as Duncan beaten again.
He was out there,
you know,
spacing out with Cosmo Molson
discussion.
You were like passing it back and forth.
So it's like you were getting at the
same depth as what they do say that
there's a certain percentage of people
it doesn't work on and I'm sure that
maybe the next time you take one more.
What is it like a lot.
How long was after a while I was getting
mad.
I was like,
come on,
but we'd wherever,
like I'll take a hit of weed and in the
afternoon or in the evening and I'm
like,
I barely affects me.
It's pleasant,
you know,
he's reading glasses on,
but in a very male kind of way.
If I do it before lunch,
I mean another,
you won't.
I didn't.
Once I met is a horrible mistake with
David Seaman.
Like before it podcast he offered me
that I took a hit and I didn't eat
before and all of a sudden in the middle
of this podcast that he's like,
I hear him talk and he heard that his
voice is coming.
The sentence is coming to an end and I'm
just like,
oh fuck,
I don't know what I'm going to say.
Oh my God.
Same substance,
one heat versus painting another case
and the 10 where it's like,
it's also different kinds of weed to
some really strong stuff,
but that's a dmt things weird that it
worked on Duncan and not you.
I wonder if maybe it's one of those
things,
man,
one of those things where you have that
thing where you don't.
It doesn't work on,
you know,
maybe he was.
Find out a report after the next one.
Young lady.
You have amazing patients.
I'm very impressed with you.
We're going to end this podcast now
because you are.
You're just going to score him yourself
into a coma.
Nikki's give daddy a kiss.
Alright,
Daniella,
you're awesome.
Next time we do this,
let's do it again and we'll,
we'll bring my kids will have a little
party.
You have a bunch of screaming back
there.
Much more or less boring guy.
Yeah.
That's how we're going to do it.
Right.
Thank you brother and your podcast.
Let people know how to get ahold of you
on twitter and your podcast.
The Bolo lists in my first initial
Daniel as a d,
e b o l e Lli on twitter,
and then a podcast is the drunken tower
with a t,
t,
a o,
s t dot.
If you guys look up Daniella calm,
which is Daniel plus,
he at the end,
b o l e Lli.
That probably refers you to every single
cells,
so that would be the easier route and
I'll just throw out there now I'm more
keen on a second podcast that's going to
happen at some point.
There's a few dig artcore.
He stood in.
You may dig this way.
It's but you know that's right now he's
on the back burner because I have to
finish writing a book.
I have to 17,000
things to take care of,
but hopefully by the beginning of the
year or something like that.
Beautiful.
All right man.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate you coming on here
and especially in tight circumstances
like this will make it happen next time.
Okay,
I'll bring my kids.
Thanks so much.
Little little kid party sound good,
everybody.
We'll see you tomorrow.
Tomorrow,
uh,
will,
will be on with Dr.
Mark Gordon,
who's going to talk about a traumatic
brain injury and post traumatic stress
disorder in soldiers were actually bring
on one of his patients who we're talking
about his experiences and hopefully we
could help some other folks out there
that are experiencing a very similar,
a similar situation.
So tomorrow.
Much love.
See you soon.
Hmm.
We pulled it off.